[Music]
all this week we've been jumping stupid
things across the world famous State
Street yeah first first we jumped a
ten-foot bratwurst which made it the
next night we unsuccessfully tried to
jump a replica of the Picasso sculpture
it crashed and sank on our next attempt
mrs. O'Leary's cow made the leap that
hit well it's time to up be Annie
tonight tonight we're staging a
competition first let's see one of
Chicago's icons mr. t let's see if he
can make the jump it's there it is it's
a replica it's a replica of mr. t the
real one refused to Rick risked his life
for this
of course mr. t held the title of
Chicago's toughest bouncer then he went
on to star as ba Baracus on the a-team
who can forget his long work as clubber
Lang in rocky 3 if you're a fool he will
pity you let's see how mr. T does
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh technically he made it let's see a
replay it looked like he landed on his
mohawk he does get a good run he makes
the jump but I think a little too much
gas he flips and mr. Chi Rio mr. Chi you
made the right choice I'm not doing that
well as I said tonight is a competition
all right mr. Teague technically made it
but he made it look easy let's find out
how an obese tourist from Green Bay
handles the jump
[Applause]
this man loves to go to Chicago bars and
talk loudly about the Packers Super Bowl
victories
[Applause]
let's see if he can make the jump he's
full of confidence this is exciting
[Applause]
yeah
wisconsin's in the united states
we show those foreigners
we've never had this feature until
tonight let's watch that spectacular
crash from our exclusive fat Green Bay
Fan handlebar camera
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh
did you see that the minute he saw he
wasn't gonna make it he just gave up
[Laughter]
graceful acceptance of death